someone right now he knows everything
that I've done in my past and it's fine
no but that's fine but what we're
talking about
um you know men we like to feel special
and in a world today where women are
running up body counts and stuff none of
us want to feel like the woman we've
chosen it we wasn't her first choice but
what if my body Count's not home no I'm
not I'm not are you just speaking no I'm
not sure
no okay sorry sorry I was a bit confused
in this moment I'm not directly aiming
at you I'm just saying because you said
you were exciting for 10 years old just
like we consider it as something like
this I'm not saying that's that's you I
don't know your body I don't want to
know your body I'm just simply trying to
say just as a man just listen to it from
from from our point of view if you never
heard it like this before just just
listen and just take it on board a
little bit that's all can I ask you a
question
sorry I don't know you know so you see
over the last 10 years when you've been
in those situation ships whatever they
were one just one yeah so it's just one
in the last two years one person and how
long did it last it lasted four years
and at any time during that situation
did you want him to be a boyfriend at
this
at the S and then I didn't want him to
be my boyfriend no okay so well two
questions firstly what happened at the
start that didn't make it become a
relationship and secondly why did he not
why did you afterwards not want him to
be a boyfriend I was in a vulnerable
state my mom passed away and I felt like
I didn't have any Woody so um the person
that wanted me I was okay with doing
the sexing
um I did want him to be my boyfriend at
first I felt like that was the direction
we was going realized it wasn't
understood what I could still get from
him
and after a while once I was done I'd be
both part of our ways
okay
but if he had wanted to be your
boyfriend during that time it would have
been a relationship right he asked me to
be his girlfriend I told him no when did
he ask you to be his girlfriend
um yeah before I broke everything off
okay fair enough but I guess it's almost
like when you got what you wanted you
didn't want it anymore
um I understood the person that I was
sleeping with and I didn't want to be in
a relationship with him but I was okay
with doing what we was doing from the
start
okay
so you carried on sleeping with him
after you realized that there was no
yeah
I didn't want to sleep around I wanted
to stay with the same person
okay fine yeah I hear girls say they do
that a lot but I guess in terms of the
relationship itself or the situation
itself I think it still stands that with
guys if he had wanted a relationship at
the beginning you would have had a
relationship I guess you know the fact
that he didn't want a relationship at
the beginning might have been why you
didn't want it afterwards but it still
kind of stays consistent with the point
that if a guy once shows interest that
he wants to have a relationship that's
really the deciding fact of a lot of
cases
um when it comes to actually having sex
it's more the girl that makes that
decided decision so you know I think
when we look at someone who hasn't had a
relationship for a certain amount of
time we normally work on the basis that
that's because the guy didn't want it um
I feel like he didn't want it and then
he did so I don't think I was in my head
about it in a way where like
I want to be in a relationship it was
very much like I like you you like me
this is what we're doing why can't we be
and then he explained himself and then I
felt a type of way but understood maybe
I wasn't ready to be in a relationship
after my vulnerable state after going
through therapy I understood that this
isn't something that I wanted life long
term it wasn't something that I wanted
to endure have kids marry with him but I
knew it was something I needed to stop
so I eventually did was he really good
looking
he was all right I'm gonna say like his
trim was a bit it's a bit did she know
him yeah yeah was he good looking would
you say
was he tall how tall was he no he's like
mine's high like five six five seven
five six five seven five seven okay okay
usually I just find that usually like if
if a girl like it's usually looks if a
girl doesn't want it I wish it was
it might have been a bit easier if it
was about looks
sorry guys um also these two are X's by
the way yeah oh yeah
boom
what he was my first boyfriend after him
I never was with anybody no no hold on
hold on a second hold on yeah yeah
is is he who you were just talking about
no he's my first boyfriend ever but they
lost everything he is the first of
everything
why didn't that work out ask him
you dump her or did she dump you I did
but it's just because like my head was
everywhere at the time I was a young boy
how old were you
[Laughter]
I agree it wouldn't be good for him
we've turned out to be really really
good friends and I appreciate that one
almost literally a thing anymore this is
crazy I was not expecting it surprised
I didn't know if you guys were going to
tell me yeah I didn't I didn't know if I
should I was like it's getting like okay
if she she gets married someday are you
I would go that's fine she's in my
bridge what do you mean you you'd go to
the wedding if I was invited I mean what
if one of her her new man said oh so
what if your new man said like this guy
has all the things you look for yeah you
know if you pass up on him it's like
that you're not getting better it's just
not happening and
he says I don't do guy friends I don't I
don't date girls that don't have guy
friends if you want to be with me but
I'm looking for a wife I'm looking for a
wife and if you want to be with me I
don't I don't date girls with guy
friends what you doing let me interject
tonight
she's being messy
um
that's hard because the guy that I love
would never say that to me but and it's
moment I'll answer it because it will be
a black and white moment it's a yeah
okay I would say
yeah because he shouldn't ever make me
feel like there was an ultimatum to
invite somebody up no longer than him
it's a standard
see this is like every time guys have a
standard I don't think you're doing it
intentionally but you kind of you kind
of Shame them for doing it so if a guy
says like I don't I don't want to date a
girl with a bunch of guy friends hanging
around I don't want to date a girl that
goes to the club you're like oh why
would you do that like that's that's
controlling if it's not controlling it's
a standard I didn't look I'm new to this
I'm so sorry what if it was the other
way around and you're
the guy has his ex as his close friend
how are you feeling like that because
I feel like it's okay it always depends
on the situation because if you look at
us for example like there hasn't been
any sexual history in like 10 years it's
been a long time but there's been sexual
history it has yeah it's been such a
long time so but if you if like when she
was seeing the other guy me and him was
cool I used to go around to the house
and chill with the ball for them it was
no problem he felt no type of way that I
was this she met because
the mother of my child that can't happen
that can't happen I've met his child
this is this is all types of disrespect
this is all types of incestors yeah this
is awesome
so so it's because we was friends before
we got into a relationship and then
after we realized that we can't be in a
relationship so we were friends when we
were babies our moms used to make us do
play dates this is getting worse
no like what you guys have done is you
guys should have just got it together
instead you guys are playing games going
into the world and you still kept this
connection you didn't want me he didn't
want me oh and that makes it even and
worse because he got rid of you see as a
man this is giving me all types of red
flags so the first so the first thing
I'm going to say you should ask him
though like no we'll get we'll get to it
okay but the first thing I want to say
as a man is as a man is you if you've
got a potential husband or boyfriend and
he said to you I'm not comfortable with
with male friends around you and if you
use that as a thing to label him as
insecure I was controlling no no no but
I'm I'm saying if you consider it as a
problem then you really don't know what
it is to be loved by a man no no no no I
mean it's really sad do you really feel
like that 100 because really yeah listen
listen oh my god listen
um I'm sorry no don't be sorry just
don't be disrespectful that's
disrespectful yes it's very
disrespectful ah listen listen listen
I'm teaching you something I'm teaching
you something okay I'm teaching you
something because when you get a man
that actually wants you and you speak
like this he's gonna go straight away
because for me this is a red flag I've
got a girl and and um there's no way she
could be having a barrage of male
friends around her yes you can she can
know males and they had them before in
their life and what have you not but
once I'm on the scene no men's can be
calling her phone she can't be saying
I'm going to be out with some with some
guy friends if we're out and male
friends see her she needs to do that and
to keep them on the other side you know
why because
that means all your male friends gotta
go you know every person that you know
every person that you know God will come
out because it's disresponsible if you
outside and you have five or six
different men that come to hug you in
front of your man that's a very big
problem so you can just you know I mean
because if I saw you with your man and
he was my friend I would do that I would
know respectfully not to come over there
and to start hugging you up in front of
your man even if they don't Bridges it's
about respect but and boundaries like
guys like you have to understand like
respect to man is love like men don't
feel loved if they don't feel respected
and in your job as a woman is to make
them look good and this goes back to
does it does it look good to a guy to
have his girl hugging the whole football
team hugging the whole basketball team
hugging hugging the whole rap scene but
I think I'm sorry to cut you but I feel
like you guys have the wrong picture of
our friendship honestly because it what
you are saying I would I understand
because personally if I was if I started
seeing a girl and she told me that she
has this really close friend now she had
history with obviously I'm always going
to feel naturally wearing pause pause
I'm always going to feel some type of
way about it however when the guy comes
into the picture and and she's seeing
the guy I will make him feel comfortable
because I'm not trying to cause no
situations because I respect her and I
respect the fact that she's now found a
new person and she's the same with me we
don't make each other's new counterparts
feel some type of way because we have
history and our history again is such a
long time ago that now it's like about
your business you're missing a point
though what if he says he's not
comfortable despite your efforts if he
says he's not comfortable to his
girlfriend then I would walk away yeah
yeah it's not your decision though it's
his girlfriend's decision right now his
girlfriend has just said that she
wouldn't listen to what he's saying and
and that's a big problem for a guy
that's a very huge problem so I would
respect it to a certain no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
it is as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible